the Jamaican Women's National team had
to create a GoFundMe page to finance
their trip to the World Cup and they
just made history by upsetting Brazil
and advancing to the round of six team
for the first time ever the GoFundMe
page has made over 45 thousand dollars
already and it's been funding the team's
training camp travel food staff support
and even the women's compensation the
team has also been receiving help from
Bob Marley's daughter sadella in 2018 a
Jamaican Women's National team was
disbanded because of a lack of funding
this is when sadella Marley knew she had
to get involved similar to her father
Cedella was also musically gifted and
she and her siblings recorded a song
called strike hard to raise funds along
with the song she created a GoFundMe
page and became the Ambassador and
sponsor of the team Marley was able to
raise three hundred thousand dollars in
the first year it has clearly not been a
smooth ride for the team financially but
even with their financial struggles it
has not flowed these women down